Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday
So our dad is a documentary film maker
And when we were growing up he worked on movies about everything
from water in Florida, to education in Alaska.
And I guess there is a case to be made that we followed in his footsteps by creating non-fiction video.
Except I don't really think of like this as a documentary.
This is more, you know, like very short podcasts featuring facial expressions.
Which is a genre of non-fiction video that is far less expensive and time consuming than documentaries
and also requires less talent for visual storytelling, which is great because even after more than ten years,
I'm still pretty bad at editing video.
But one thing I did inherit from Dad was a really deep love for documentary films.
Like, Hank, as you know, my dream job has always been...you know what...
I'm about to date myself, but there used to be this widely adopted technology called cable television.
Basically you would pay a monthly fee in exchange for access to lots of video content.
So it was sort of like Netflix, except for some reason you still had to watch advertisements..
It was a weird time...but anyways,
there were these cable stations that just showed old movies all day!
Like one of them was called "Turner Classic Movies,"
And before these movies started, there would be this person who would introduce the movie to you
and talk about some of the historical context and who the stars were.
Now it occurs to me in retrospect that the introducer probably existed mostly to make the movie longer...
like, if you can stretch a 90 minute movie into 120 minutes of content, then you could add 8 minutes of advertising.
But when I was a kid that was my dream job, to be an introducer.
But not regular movies, of documentaries.
These days, documentaries are a lot easier to discover than they were when I was a kid.
Netflix, for instance, has an excellent and extensive library, but
still, many of my favorite documentaries
aren't on Netflix. Like I'm thinking of
the "7UP" series, where a filmmaker has
checked in every seven years with a
group of people since they were kids in
the 1960s. Or "Herb & Dorothy," a movie about
a postal worker and a librarian living
in New York City who became two of the world's leading art collectors.
For the classic, "Complaints of a dutiful Daughter,"
a gut-wrenching and sometimes hilarious
movie about a woman whose mother has Alzheimer's.
Or "Slavery by Another Name,"
a movie about the failures of
reconstruction and the post-civil war
United States. There are so many great
documentaries and so few of them ever
find a broad audience. But as a kid, my
favorite genre of documentary was the
nature documentary, where you can see
animals in the wild like fighting to
survive. I love nature docs because they
felt like a glimpse into a world
without us, I mean they almost never
include humans in the frame and there's
something magical about that. But of
course in real life humans can't be
separated from nature, I mean we're
currently nature's most important
species, and the choices we're making
affect every other species on Earth. And
that's what I love so much about the
movie Kedi and why I wanted us to help
in its distribution. Kedi uses all the
conventions of the nature documentary -
you get the beautiful cinematography, the
fight scenes, the plucky underdog is
struggling to survive, the parents caring
for babies, but it doesn't exclude humans
from the story.  Instead we see the
connecting points between a city and its
people and its cats. It is a nature
documentary that acknowledges that
humans are part of nature. And it shows
that life for cats is sometimes tender
and sometimes cold and always
unpredictable, as it is for humans. Now I
know that Kedi is currently only
available via purchase or YouTube red
and that makes it inaccessible to a lot
of you. One of the big challenges with
documentaries is that it's really hard
to fund them on advertising revenue
alone, which is why so few of them are
available on free streaming services, at
least legally. But regardless, if you do
have a chance to see it someday, I really
hope you do. It's a wonderful movie. While
I'm fulfilling my dream of being an
introducer, two other recommendations: if
you live in the United States, PBS has
some excellent documentaries that are
actually available for free. Also,
wherever you live, there is a free and
ongoing documentary project that you
might enjoy called "The road to Nerdfighteria"
about how different people
found this little corner of the internet
and what it means to them. They're still
accepting submissions and it's a really
wonderful series, links in the doobly-doo below.
Hank. I will see you on Friday.
End Screen! Hank, I actually won't see you
on Friday, that was misleading and I
apologize, but I'm going to be taking
like a week or possibly two weeks away
from the internet to focus on some
writing things. But there will be a video
next Tuesday, it's just that I recorded it in advance.
Okay, check out Kedi and The Road to Nerdfighteria! Bye!